l'article que l'on va lire aujourd'hui
c'est un article un peu spéciale en tout
cas dans la jeunesse à deux titres le
premier bain c'est un petit peu le choix
qui a été opéré pour cet article en fait
c'est dans un stream précédent
on a discuté avec un follower peut-être
qu'il va être là tout à l'heure vers
alex ou requin ça dépend un petit peu il
a dû pseudo bien avec lui on a discuté
de différentes choses et il se trouve
qu'il devait faire un travail sur
l'exploitation des rationnel le
bénévolat et il me disait qu'il avait
beaucoup d'articles à lire et je lui ai
proposé finalement d'en lire 1 avec avec
lui ou pas un peu importe
justement pour l'aider mais c'était
aussi intéressant pour nous d'aborder ce
thème là alors c'est un thème qui a été
souvent abordé par mes élèves quand ils
ont des travaux de fin d'année ou de fin
d'études à faire j'ai déjà eu deux
élèves qui ont vraiment aborder un thème
très proche et donc voilà le choix a été
fait de cette manière là c'est un petit
peu plus original que d'habitude parce
que d'habitude en fait qu'est-ce qui se
passe et bien sûr youtube
puisque je vous le disais cette chaîne
la société qui est d'abord une chaîne
youtube sur youtube vous retrouvez
chaque semaine un vote qui vous est
proposé avec différents articles de
sciences sociales alors je vais vous
montrer ce qui va bientôt vous être
proposé parce que bon c'est toujours
généralement la fin du stream que le
vote pour la semaine suivante sort et
donkey 6 à 22 heures passées de 22
heures pourrait voter je vous ai proposé
tout d'abord un article qui va
traiter de la scolarisation de trois
élèves hp ensuite on à la pulvérisation
démocratique où les clivages façon
puzzle un thème un peu plus politique et
enfin les inégalités sociales
disposition et usages du numérique donc
voilà vous avez toute la semaine pour
voter et l'article qui ressortira en
tête bien sera celui qu'on découvrira la
semaine prochaine
si vous avez le cas échéant des articles
à proposer n'hésitez pas ainsi il rentre
dans le cadre de la chaîne et bien je
les soumettrait au vote et je vous dis
ya juste cette fois le choix s'est fait
un peu de manière différente alors on va
découvrir le travail de mode simonet qui
est chercheuse en sociologie et
directrice de recherche au cnrs qui est
le centre national de la recherche
scientifique un oui il ya une recherche
officielle d'état j'avais envie d'y être
financés par l'état en sociologie aussi
il n'y a pas que pour combattre les
maladies qu'on fait des recherches et
qu'on finance de la recherche mais aussi
des recherches en sciences sociales et
donc c'est tout à fait intéressant et
donc dans son article ici on va en
parler un petit peu plus elle va nous
parler vraiment de d'un travail de fond
qu'elle a réalisé et c'est vraiment
l'évolution de tout son objet d'étude
qui va être qui va être analysé ici en
fait elle est spécialiste du bénévolat
et aussi du volontariat c'est à dire
toutes les formes de travail qui sont
invisibles ou qui ne sont pas reconnus
socialement et elle va nous expliquer
comment finalement de fil en aiguille au
fur et à mesure de ses recherches elle a
changé un peu le cadre théorique et la
problématique dans laquelle elle
s'inscrivait alors souvent les élèves
qui font des travaux ont des difficultés
à définir une problématique évidemment
je ne propose pas ici à des élèves de
secondaire de faire le même travail que
beauty monnaie mais par son travail vous
allez comprendre ce qu'est une bonne
problématique et comment bien la choisir
alors l'article est disponible sur kairn
évidemment c'est des articles qui sont
payants donc je ne peux malheureusement
pas
voulait donner sinon je contreviendrait
aux
à la propriété intellectuelle
intellectuelle est donc ici voilà je
vais juste vous lire quelques passages à
des fins de vulgarisation mais vous
aurez l'essentiel donc le titre de la
recherche ici en tout cas de l'article
s'appelle parce qu'il va parler de
plusieurs recherches s'appelle
l'exploitation des bénévoles point
d'interrogation des questions de l'anc
est au questionnement des catégories
n'est pas très long vous voyez qu'il
fait cette page parfois on lit des
articles qui font plus de 20 pages au
qu'ici normalement ça ira assez vite la
manière d'opérer toujours la même je
vous propose finalement
un travail de pré lecture ici j'ai déjà
lu une première fois et lors de cette
première lecture j'ai souligné les
éléments qui me semble essentiel pour
comprendre l'ensemble du texte mais il
ne s'agit pas sur un texte aussi long
que je vous lis tout je le fais quand
l'article est plus petit que celui ci
bon on a eu il ya deux semaines un
article de 4 pages est donc là c'était
tout à fait faisable mais je vois pas
l'intérêt de lire un article complet
d'autant plus que ici c'est un article
qui ep1 me semble utile
alors ce qu'elle veut faire maud simone
essaie de nous exposer les étapes
empirique d'un itinéraire théorique qui
commence avec la sociologie de
l'engagement et débouche sur une notion
celle d'exploitation donc en fait de fil
en aiguille à travers toutes ces
explorations à travers toutes ces
recherches
ici c'est les étapes empirique donc
c'est par rapport aux observations
qu'elle a pu faire sur le terrain
finalement elle a elle a évolué
théoriquement pour passer d'une
sociologie de l'engagement qui est très
politique 1 pourquoi est-ce qu'on
s'engage mais c'est peut-être pour
donner du sens pour certaines actions
à une notion qui est plutôt celles
d'exploitation donc là où on est
finalement utilisé à certaines fins donc
ça c'est intéressant parce que là il ya
vraiment un décalage qui va s'opérer
mais vous allez voir si veut c'est pas
très clair pour vous ça va s'éclaircir
au fur et à mesure de la lecture
alors ici l'objet de sa thèse est
l'objet de ces travaux c'est
l'engagement bénévole c'est à dire le
bénévolat c'est à dire les activités non
rémunérées alors elle va s'intéresser
à ce qui se passe en france et aux états
unis dans la suite de l'héritage
tocqueville liens dans lequel je
m'inscris vais alors parce qu'elle a un
peu changé la problématique et son axe
d'étude et qui accorder une place
centrale au bénévolat dans le modèle de
démocratie américain et salue vers alex
comment vas tu et bien voilà on a
commencé à lire l'article que tu nous
avais proposé si tu as des questions ou
des remarques à faire évidemment
n'hésite pas le chat est à toi ou à vous
si vous êtes plus nombreux sur le stream
ce soir et donc ça c'est intéressant
qu'elle fasse référence à togoville
puisque c'est un auteur qu'on aborde en
secondaire que trouvera d'ailleurs une
vidéo où j'expose un petit peu les
points essentiels de la pensée de
tocqueville dans la société qu sûr sur
youtube et donc tocqueville c'est
vraiment le théoricien de la démocratie
aux états unis puisqu'il s'intéresse à
cette démocratie là étant donné que pour
lui elle a une forme relativement pure
c'est à dire que les états unis n'ont
pas dû évoluer d'un ancien régime vers
un nouveau régime ce a directement été
un nouveau régime contrairement à la
france ou à la grande-bretagne où on
avait une aristocratie et finalement
après l'avènement d'une démocratie
à la place de cette aristocratie et donc
pour tocqueville des états unis sont
vraiment un laboratoire tocqueville les
français et donc c'est vraiment un
laboratoire pour lui de la démocratie et
au sein de cette démocratie américaine
l'engagement des citoyens dans des
organisations est essentiel parce que
pour lui c'est vraiment ce qui est
fondateur et ce qui relie chaque
individu les uns ou l'autre les uns aux
autres et donc c'est dans cet engagement
bénévole alors là je travaillais un
petit peu tocqueville parce que je pense
qu'ils ne parlent pas de bénévoles mais
c'est dans cet engagement associatif ou
dans différentes organisations qu'il va
trouver de la cohérence sociale
finalement et du sens au sens de
d'avoir une société dans laquelle on
voit sa place où on est quoi
quel lien j'ai avec les autres et
finalement qu'on est bien dans un dans
une société où il ya du collectif parce
qu' un
pléonasme évidemment
super si tu connais d'autres villes tu
vois ça fait référence alors à ce à quoi
alors ce matin quand j'ai lu l'article
je me suis dis bah tiens je vais je vais
rechercher tocqueville mais j'ai
complètement oublié ça donc c'est
maintenant en découvrant l'article que
je revois que quand on a fait je devais
faire ça mais voilà au bronze parler
éventuellement plus tard
et donc on voit là qu'il ya un parti
pris déjà théorique à la base de ces
travaux
et donc c'est ici
comment dire la notion essentielle de sa
première approche c'est qu'elle voit
l'engagement bénévole comme un mode de
participation politique on s'engage
bénévolement parce que voilà on a des
idées aux politiques et on veut agir
politiquement
et ça c'est vraiment le point de départ
mais tu vas voir qu'il va évoluer
tout au long de ces travaux puisque ici
elle ne fait pas le résumé d'un seul
d'une seule recherche mais vraiment elle
fait plutôt un retour réflexif sur
l'ensemble de ces évolutions et donc
elle va vraiment dépassé ce mode de
participation politique comme porte
d'entrée vers le bénévolat
et donc les questions qu'elles se posent
au départ on la retrouve dans différents
travaux alors dans tout travail
scientifique il y aura une partie qui
sera consacrée à l'état de l'art où on
va un petit peu regardé ce qui avait
déjà été fait précédemment donc tu vois
ici il y avait des travaux de bénédicte
à havard duclos et sandrine ni cour en
2005 et alors elle disait maintient
l'engagement associatif constitue-t-il
une sinon la nouvelle forme d'engagement
politique puisque on constate que dans
nos sociétés
être militant c'est quelque chose qu'on
fait de moins en moins et encore moins
dans un parti politique et donc on peut
se demander tient à ce qu'il y'a pas des
vases communicants avec un engagement
dans le bénévolat qui va remplacer cet
engagement politique et donc ça c'est
vraiment la construction de du bénévolat
comme mode d'engagement et d'ailleurs
comme on en avait déjà discuté et bien
ça c'est vraiment la problématique qui
avait abordé par les élèves avec qui on
avait travaillé ce thème là quoi
d'ailleurs
et donc on a vraiment là un paradigme
dominant dans les années 90 où on fait
c'est quand tu ouvres des travaux sur le
bénévolat bien on en revient toujours à
cette notion d'engagement et de
remplacement finalement de l'engagement
politique politique par un engagement
bénévole
en ce qui concerne je n'y ai pas échappé
c'est bien de ce cadrage de théorique de
l'objet relevant d'une sociologie
politique somme toute assez classique
que je suis parti voilà et elle s'est
vraiment inscrit dans ses rails la cua
et alors elle nous dit et c'est ça que
je trouve intéressant pour des gens qui
font des recherches en sciences sociales
ça nous permet de comprendre ce que j'ai
ce cas une bonne coupe problématique on
voit que là ce thème de l'engagement
politique il a déjà été travaillé et
retravaillé
quand on s'intéresse au bénévolat est
donc cette problématique là d' bay n'est
plus très intéressante puisqu'elle n'est
plus très haut très original on a un
petit peu fait le tour de la question et
on voit pas très bien où en tout cas
paul simonard ne voit pas très bien
comment elle va mot de pardon pas pôle
maud simonard ne voit pas très bien
comment elle va apporter quelque chose
de nouveau comment elle va apporter sa
petite pierre à l'édifice et donc ça
c'est intéressant pour choisir une
problématique une bonne problématique ça
peut être un angle d'attaqué de tout
objet qui va être totalement novateur
alors c'est très difficile évidemment
quand on est un élève du secondaire ii
d'inventer quelque chose de tout à fait
nouveau ça dépendra du niveau du
chercheur évidemment mais une bonne
problématique c'est qu'elle sait quelque
chose qui va renouveler finalement tout
ce qui a déjà été fait sans grand
intérêt et sans grand apport surtout
temps qu'il m'apparaissait que cette
question de l'engagement faisait déjà
l'objet d'une importante littérature
souvent fondées sur des enquêtes
empiriques de qualité donc une enquête
empirique pour rappel un pouce il ya
vraiment des débutants sur le stream
c'est une observation et donc on a sans
doute des observations déjà très poussée
avec des entretiens qualitatifs avec des
observations
plus quantitative comme des
questionnaires ou peut-être des
observations directes que sais-je et
donc ça c'était déjà travaillé avec des
débats dans lesquels je pouvais
m'inscrire mais sans véritablement est
renouvelée et huayi elle se rend compte
que cette problématique là n'est pas la
plus la plus porteuse quoi il me
semblait al'inverse que peu de gens
s'étaient intéressés à ce qui
m'apparaissait alors comme une
découverte cruciale de mon travail dans
la quête et que je ne mets alors faute
de mieux ses dimensions du travail au
coeur des engagements et donc elle de
son côté elle fait des observations en
france et aux états unis et elle se rend
compte que les acteurs de terrain lui
remonte des informations mais qui sont
totalement absentes quoi c'est vraiment
ces acteurs de terrain on le verra plus
tard mais je conduis j'introduis déjà
cette idée la voix l'engagement bénévole
comme comme une sorte de travail
certainement pas rémunéré mais comme une
sorte de travail quand même
et donc on est autour de cette question
finalement d'un engagement citoyen mais
parfois indemnisé même est ce que je
disais dans ses enquêtes empiriques
temps les bénévoles français que les
bénévoles américains font
systématiquement recours à des termes
web du lexique comme travail comme ici
je travaille mon travail c'est je
travaille avec et donc voilà ils sont
pas dans un commentaire dans une dans
une démarche politique qui serait voilà
de de changer la société ou d'influer
sur celle ci non non c'est vraiment un
travail relativement personnel j'ai
envie de dire mais ça c'est une
interprétation je fais mais enfin et
avec pas humain qui n'a pas une
dimension de changer les choses quoi ou
d'impacter la société d'un point de vue
politique et donc ce qui est aussi
intéressant c'est qu'il met en évidence
les liens entre l'activité bénévole
exercer et la carrière professionnelle
passée futur ou en cours réel ou idéal
donc il s'associa ça
ils associent leur travail bénévole à
leurs activités professionnelles il ya
vraiment un échange entre les deux
le travail appréhendé comme rapport
social et institutionnel non simplement
sous l'angle de l'activité il en appelle
à une analyse du travail bénévole dans
ses dimensions plus politique plus
institutionnels notamment conflictuelle
ainsi la grève des bénévoles des restos
du coeur qui se produit en octobre 2001
une cinquantaine de bénévoles parisien
des camions du coeur se mettent en grève
pour protester contre la décision prise
par le conseil d'administration de
l'association de distribuer des
sandwichs à la place des plats chauds je
constate également que des bénévoles
intenté parfois gagne des procès au
cours duquel desquels pardon les
activent leur activité de bénévole se
voir requalifier en contrat de travail
requalification qui pouvait être
également intenté par l'urssaf en france
où le department of labor aux états unis
et parfois contre la volonté des
bénévoles eux-mêmes et donc on voit que
dans leur mode de commande ya de lutte
ou leur mode de contestation dans cette
sphère bénévoles a bien on retrouve des
mécanismes qu'on peut retrouver par
rapport au monde du travail ou par
rapport simplement à une reconnaissance
de cette activité bénévole comme une
activité issus du travail et donc cela
la conforte un petit peu dans sa vision
dans sa découverte que le bénévolat
est moins à travailler sous le thème de
l'engagement que sous le thème de
l'activité
professionnelle seront pas dire
professionnelle mais l'activité
l'activité de cours
voilà il ya une sorte de question de la
syndicalisation des volontaires
finalement qui vont se se positionner et
se défendre et s'organiser comme des
travailleurs et plus j'avançais dans mes
enquêtes plus j'avais le sentiment d'un
décalage d'un manque entre ce que je
comprenais du fonctionnement de ces
morts monde du bénévolat et la manière
dont la sociologie s'étaient emparés de
l'objet bénévolat en le confiant dans la
division du travail sociologique à la
sociologie politique exclusivement et
donc elle elle se rend compte qu'il ya
tout un champ qui n'a pas été explorée
et évidemment elle s'y engouffre c'est
ça
c'est ça une bonne problématique
en russie elle donne donne des exemples
elle explique aussi qu'elle va avoir une
lecture qui est ici qui va être un
déclencheur et c'est une lecture qui en
fait n'a rien à voir directement avec le
bénévolat puisque c'est une lecture qui
parlent
des femmes
qui notamment voilà ont des activités
ménagères qui ne sont pas forcément
reconnu
et c'est une vision enfin en fait c'est
des travaux qui sont des travaux
féministe puisque la femme est souvent
cantonné à des tâches ménagères en tout
cas dans les années 80 c'est toujours le
cas maintenant on en fait les travaux
qui sont proposés ici date des années 80
et finalement elle va faire le parallèle
entre ces tâches ménagères et le travail
bénévole qui est aussi souvent occupés
par des femmes et donc ça c'est aussi
intéressant pour une recherche il faut
pas forcément lire que des choses qui
sont directement liés
à l'objet d'études pourquoi mais parce
que parfois justement c'est des
transpositions d'autres d'autres objets
qui vont permettre de comprendre
certaines choses c'est de voir qu'il ya
des schémas beaucoup plus globaux qui
peuvent s'inscrire et qui se décline
dans sur différents objets à la fois ici
le travail ménager et le travail
bénévole
regardez le bénévolat comme du travail
c'était tout simplement aller rechercher
les bons outils théoriques pour un naze
et le fait que les interviewer les
interviewés notamment
nomme pardon et décrivent leurs
pratiques comme tels que les
associations se mettent à manager les
bénévoles que des bénévoles mécontents
se mettent en grève et que les tribunaux
vont qualifie parfois la pratique en
travail dissimulé et donc quand elle
parle ici des bons outils théoriques et
bien c'est ceux qui sont issus de sa
lecture féministe des événements
je saisis bien néanmoins sans en tirer
encore toutes les conséquences qu'en
parlant de travail bénévole je mime le
mouvement qui a été celui des féministes
à propos du travail domestique que je
pose à mon objet main à meaux j'ai la
même question qu'elles ont posé aux
activités domestiques et si on regarde
ça comme du travail qu'est ce qu'on voit
et donc c'est vraiment
la problématique qui va être adoptée qui
va
produire du travail un fois intéressant
et novateur
et le trait d'union finalement entre le
travail bénévole et le travail
domestique c'est ce concept de travail
invisible
un travail est quelque chose qui produit
quand même quelque chose mais qui est
tout à fait d'évaluer socialement et
aussi économiquement
et donc de fil en aiguille elle en
arrive sur de nouveaux concepts de
nouvelles notions qu'elle va intégrer
dans ses recherches c'est faire émerger
des interrogations en terme de travail
gratuit et d'exploitation parce que
évidemment si tu produis quelque chose
du service du bien bénévolement mais il
est toujours récupérer quelque part est
donc là de là vient le terme
d'exploitation sans que je ne sache très
bien au départ comment les appréhender
théoriquement et donc on comprend
pourtant ici voilà mode simonard est une
chercheuse professionnels qui consacre
tout son temps à ça et on voit qu'elle
est vraiment en difficulté pour
arriver à quelque chose tout à fait
construit bon ici elle nous propose
quelque chose d'abouti parce que voilà
il a eu tout le temps d'y réfléchir et
d'arriver finalement quelque chose mais
ça doit rassurer aussi tous ceux qui
font des recherches et des études en
sciences sociales un c'est que à ce
moment on patauge vraiment quoi mais je
dis souvent aux élèves il faut faire
confiance au cerveau et si vous restez
suffisamment open à saint amand tout va
s'éclaircir à un certain moment quoi
plus ou moins
plus ou moins longtemps après le début
de votre recherche mais il faut pas
s'inquiéter c'est le sait la normalité
du processus de recherche tout ça c'est
mon avis ici elle donne deux exemples en
riant n'avait pas retenu l'autre me
semble plus intéressant je lire
intégralement ces interrogations
relatives aux usages du travail
invisible à son appropriation et plus
largement à l'économie politique dans
laquelle ils s'inscrivent n'ont pas
manqué d'avoir des échos et se sont même
amplifié sur un autre terrain que je
venais de commencer alors avec mon
collègue américain john krynski cette
enquête intitulée brooklyn new york parc
porté sur la trans sur les
transformations du travail dans les
parcs de la ville de new york depuis la
crise budgétaire des années 1970 1970
elle s'intéressait à la démultiplication
des statuts des travailleurs et des
travailleuses qui s'y était produite et
notamment au développement du bénévolat
et du workfare lui offrir et
l'obligation faite aux allocataires de
l'aide sociale de donner des heures de
travail pour continuer à toucher leurs
allocations c'est l'idée qui arrive dans
certains pays d'europe ou chez certains
politiques dans ce petit service public
municipal d'entretien des parcs à cette
eau dans notre enquête
krynski et moi nous sommes retrouvés
face à un haut fonctionnaire de la ville
de new york qui nous a expliqué qu'au
cours des années 1990 ce service
municipal l'entretien des parcs de new
york avait été mis en concurrence avec
des entreprises privées
dans le cadre d'une expérimentation
menée sur quelques quartiers du queens
afin d'établir s'il n'était pas plus
rentable de privatiser l'entretien des
parcs municipaux alors qu'ils nous
annoncent non sans fierté que le
département des parcs a gagné contre
l'entreprise privée et conservait de ce
fait le monopole l'entretien des parcs
il ajoute we have something corporation
donne des fruits d'abord donc ce free
d'abord ce travail gratuit qu'il a en
tête et dont il n'hésitera pas à dire
qu'il a sauvé le département des parcs
c'est avant tout celui des milliers
d'allocataires de l'aide sociale que la
ville de new york utilisait alors pour
nettoyer ses parcs sans les payer ou
très peu puisque leur allocation était
essentiellement prise en charge par
l'état de new york et l'état fédéral
c'est aussi comme le reste de
l'entretien le mettra en évidence le
free l'abord de milliers de bénévoles
dont l'engagement est encouragée et
soutenue par différents programmes
associatifs et un important partenariat
public privé par chip cox
financé à la fois par le département des
parcs de la ville de new york et par une
grande fondation privée la saisie par
svendsen donc là ce qui est super
intéressant c'est que
tu te rends compte que le travail
bénévole est une ressource économique
finalement qui va être utilisé alors ici
pas forcément pour en retirer une plus
value si j'utilisais le vocabulaire de
marx mais en tout cas pour en retirer un
avantage
organisationnel ou compétitif compétitif
me semble être le mot le mot approprié
d'autant plus que dans le premier
exemple voilà je ne vais pas le dire ici
dans le premier exemple le travail
bénévole d'apporter un comment dire un
avantage compétitif à certains acteurs
par rapport à d'autres qui ne peuvent
pas bénéficier de ce travail bénévole
vraiment ça me fait penser à plein de
choses cela
il ya une sorte aussi de dévolution mais
ça c'est voilà c'est un exemple que je
donne pour faire un peu parler l'article
c'est met ses pas dans cet article ne
faut pas l'associer à l'article c'est
par exemple ici dans l'école de mon
village on a demandé si quelqu'un
pouvait venir aider un petit élève qui
était trisomique en fait qui soulevaient
de trisomie 21
et donc voilà c'était les bénévoles mais
moi je me souviens qu'à l'époque ça m'a
un peu choqué dans le sens pas à combien
pas bien sûr qu'on vienne aider ce petit
élève mais dans le sens où
mais finalement c'est le travail
bénévole qui va prendre la place fruit
d'un travail qui aurait pu être
rémunérés par l'état quoi puisque moi il
me semble que voilà c'est ça l'état de
d'offrir des structures qui vont aider
les plus faibles c'est comme ça que je
le vois maman je suis un défenseur de de
l'état providence et donc on voit que le
travail bénévole peut être une variable
d'ajustement relativement économique et
donc de cette là les acteurs qui sont
impliqués dans ce travail bénévole belle
voix aussi comme comme un travail en
tant que tel
le recours aux bénévoles
aux allocataires duo pendant le recours
aux bénévoles et aux allocataires au
workfare permet à la municipalité de new
york de garder le monopole de
l'entretien des parcs alors que le
nombre de parts qu'ils les
fonctionnaires municipaux protéger et
syndiqué de ce petit service public ne
cesse de diminuer depuis la fiscale
krisis des années 1970
voilà donc le travail bénévole
finalement s'intègre dans quelque chose
de beaucoup plus général peut-on parler
d'exploitation dans des espaces qui ne
relèvent pas du travail mais de ce que
la société range du côté du hors travail
justement et c'est que le travail du
sociologue est particulièrement
intéressant c'est de montrer que le
travail bénévole n'est pas un autre
travail puisqu'ils à ce moment il
intervient ou alors il est mal géré il
est le lieu de même lutte que dans le
monde du travail
l'engagement pour les bénévoles
l'assistance pour les allocataires de
l'aide sociale peut-on parler
d'exploitation dans un service public et
ati l'exploitation si on peut à
proprement parler mesure et de profits
pour l'organisation faut-il alors
substitué à la mesure du profit celle
des économies réalisées sur le coût du
travail par la municipalité
voilà parce qu'on parle souvent par
rapport à un truc du travail rémunéré
des bénéfices que peut faire
l'entreprise mais ici c'est plutôt des
économies qui peuvent être faits par
bompas par une entreprise mais par les
pouvoirs publics et donc ici tu as toute
une batterie de questions mais qui sont
limite incluses dans cette nouvelle
problématique
at on affaire ici à une exploitation
capitaliste alors que nous rencontrons
crise qui est moi à notre grande
surprise d'ailleurs pas d'une seule
entreprise privée sur notre terrain dans
kate mais uniquement un service
municipal des associations et donc c'est
aussi ça qui est intéressant c'est que
c'est pas forcément les entreprises
privées qui font appel à ce travail
bénévole comme variable d'ajustement
c'est des associations et des services
municipaux
cette notion d'exploitation suffit-elle
à décrire le processus historique que
l'on mettra progressivement lumière et
qui relève moins d'une privatisation du
service public au sens traditionnel du
terme que d'une gratuit gratuite isation
de celui ci ça c'est super aussi
intéressant quoi tu vois le service
public ne se privatise pas on ne confie
pas au privé mais finalement le confier
aux bénévoles
ça c'est quand même quelque chose qui
n'est pas très très conscient quoi le
travail bénévole finalement le le rôle
de ce travail bénévole dans dans les
économies
publiques
et puis ce qui est ce qu elles
renseignent aussi c'est que le travail
bénévole qui est un travail invisible
est majoritairement féminin
et donc de là le lien avec le travail
bennage et qui lui aussi est
principalement féminin et qui est aussi
un travail qui n'est pas valorisé
socialement
jusqu'où peut-on alors sérieusement
utiliser le même terme d'exploitation
pour désigner également l'utilisation
par la ville du travail de ces acteurs
qui sont en grande partie là aussi des
actrices bénévoles bonne voisine et
bonne citoyenne issus des classes
moyennes supérieures qui que rien a
priori n'oblige est là sinon tu
delaplane une toute une panoplie de
normes sociales et janry j'aime bien le
terme toute une panoplie de normes
sociales et j'aurai le
terme panoplie chouf et bien et bien dit
ben voilà on s'imagine bien un petit peu
j'imagine desperate housewife voyez un
petit peu qu'ils vont passer du temps
pour
justifier ou se donner bonne conscience
par rapport à des revenus importants
qu'elle pourrait gagner ou que leurs
compagnons ramènerait pour le ménage
quoi et voilà c'est le travail bénévole
qui va te permettre de te racheter et de
bien paraître socialement
il est vraiment vraiment toute une
richesse dans cette problématique
et donne à voir combien ce travail
gratuit des femmes dans les parcs au nom
de la citoyenneté est terriblement pris
dans des rapports sociaux de classe et
de race entre une citoyenneté comment
trg et qu'on valorise pour les unes et
une citoyenneté qu'on démontre et qu'on
rachète pour les autres ben oui parce
que en fait un mix ac est tout à fait
originale entre bien les personnes
issues des classes plus populaires qui
vont être soumis aux travaux d'intérêts
généraux ou d'intérêt général je suis
patient sur la corde
et aux états unis tu sais bien que les
classes populaires c'est d'abord des
classes qui sont noirs ou qui sont issus
des minorités ethniques d'être bientôt
plus minoritaires pour le coup et 2c de
ces femmes
plutôt blanche plutôt
de bonnes conditions sociales et donc y
aura un mix quoi donc les unes vont
vouloir montrer le rôle de bonnes
citoyennes les autres vont vouloir
racheter leur conduite de citoyenne
en plongeant dans les analyses
féministes sur le travail domestique et
l'exploitation à laquelle il donne lieu
j'ai réalisé à quel point la perspective
féministe ou plutôt les perspectives
féministes dans leurs débats et à
travers leur contreverse offrait des
éléments de cadrage à mes différentes
questions et donc elle voit que ces
outils-là
de compréhension féministes
sont intéressants alors c'est quelque
part dans l'article précise en plus que
l à la base elle n'est pas forcément
porté sur le travaux aux féministes
c'est pas forcément les travaux qu'elle
a qualifiés et donc c'est vraiment au
fil de ses recherches qu'elle trouve la
pertinence de ces outils là pour
comprendre son objet d'étude ces
analyses féministes invité en effet à
penser le travail gratuit non pas comme
une soustraction
un travail moins une rémunération mais
comme bien un déni de travail et ce au
nom de valeurs au nom de l'amour pour le
travail domestique c'est pas du travail
c'est de l'amour au nom de la
citoyenneté pour les formes physiques
civique pardon de travail gratuit je
dirais voilà qui est une sorte
d'homologie entre le travail domestique
et le travail bénévole ou d'un côté on
ne le paient pas parce que le travail
domestique ben voilà c'est du travail de
bonnes mères quoi on fait ça par amour
et travail bénévole c'est du travail de
bonnes citoyennes ont fait sa part
par amour du social quoi fin de la
société j'ai pas comme on pourrait le
dire
cc et c'est assez intéressant comme ça a
été construit
cette appropriation des théories
féministes de l'exploitation appelé par
mes questionnements pays qui a débouché
sur une vaste interrogation sur les
figures et forme de l'exploitation avec
lesquels on réfléchit aujourd'hui plus
largement sur le genre de nos catégories
d'analysé en sociologie du travail donc
c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle
revoyons nos catégories ou quelque chose
comme ça dans le titre c'est que
finalement
il ya tout un travail de
conceptualisations à faire les mêmes de
construction de ces concepts commentait
ce qu'on a construit des concepts et
commentait ce qu'on a construit des
objets d'étude avec ces concepts et
finalement parfois il faut déconstruire
jusqu'au concept même amour aux théories
même qui avait été
sous entendus jusque-là points
la première c'est de réfléchir à ce que
l'on pourrait gagner en tant que
sociologue du travail et peut-être aussi
pourquoi à ce que l'on aurait pu perdre
à perdre à investir une approche
empirique de l'exploitation comme je
viens de le proposer trop rapidement ici
mais nos concepts sont aussi parfois
déjà riche en représentation au sens où
ils sont à la fois déjà chargé
théoriquement et c'est ça le problème
quoi de joie le bénévolat c'est déjà un
concept construit qui était déjà chargé
d'une certaine vision des choses qu'elle
a réussi à déconstruire de par basque
elle explique ici coin pourtant quand
les sociologues du travail dispense
analyse observe le travail très peu et
intègre encore aujourd'hui le travail
domestique le travail bénévole et le
travail gratuit
alors que c'est vécu comme du travail
avec la question de l'exploitation des
bénévoles c'est dans une économie
politique empirique et féministe que
vient désormais s'inscrire cet objet
bénévolat analyser comme travail gratuit
c'est bien ces enjeux de définition de
ce qui est productif de ceux qui créent
de ceux qui créent ou non de la valeur
soulevé par louise vandelac comme par de
nombreuses féministes matérialise que la
question de l'exploitation des bénévoles
nous invite à penser à nouveau à partir
des leçons du domestique laborde et bed
mais au delà du seul travail domestique
elle met en lumière à travers l'analyse
de la gratuite isation du travail dans
les services publics par exemple
l'extension des territoires du travail
gratuit et avec elle la multiplication
des modes de mobilisation et
d'appropriation de formes diverses du
travail non reconnu comme tel le
bénévolat le volontariat le workfare les
stages ou warfare pour rappel s'est dit
un peu dans l'article c'est vraiment
comme des travaux d'intérêts généraux
étaient obligés de faire pour garder tes
droits en tant que locataire sociale par
exemple
pour saisir cette exploitation du
travail au nom de valeurs dites hors
travail qui l'invisible is il convient
alors de descendre au centre et nos
catégories d'analysé de penser ensemble
la question de la valeur économique et
celle sociologique et politique des
valeurs
voilà donc c'est vraiment un travail qui
est intéressant pour comprendre la
construction d'un objet d'étude d'études
me semble-t-il et comprendre
l'importance de choisir une
problématique est de questionner
peut-être les problématiques qui sont
déjà très attaché à certains objets
comme ici et ici à pas mal de concepts
qui peuvent être utilisés je pense que
même un élève du secondaire pourrait
reprendre certaines choses qui sont
dites ici peut être investigués aussi
toute cette chose déjà plus classique
delà des sciences sociales qui est
l'invisibilisation du travail domestique
1 ce qui est dit mais aussi voilà
toute cette invisibilisation du travail
de bénévoles quoi
alors je regarde ce que tu
verras l'ex voilà j'espère que la
lecture de l'article t'as permis d'y
voir un peu plus clair à mon avis et
c'est à la fois un bon article pour
votre travail mais je ne sais pas
exactement quelle est la nature du
travail même temps c'est pas un article
qui va apporter beaucoup d'éléments mais
en tout cas ça t'apporte une
problématique 1 c'est toute cette
problématique du du travail bénévole
comme un vrai travail
est de bien montrer que à côté d'une
problématique plus lié à l'engagement
politique
c'est un petit peu ce qu'on avait
discuté dernière fois bien il ya une
autre problématique ici qui est très
présente avec les travaux de l'auteur
maintenant c'est peut-être déjà plus
avec tes lectures que j'ai réalisé
dans le travail bénévole sont payés par
une sorte valeurs comme le sentiment
d'être utiles ou encore quelque chose
naturelle si nous regardons le livre
bénédicte hervé duclos sandrine nicourt
le bénévolat n'est pas le résultat d'une
volonté individuelle le bénévole agit
certes parce que sa trajectoire
familiale sa socialisation notamment
dans l'enfance lui ont permis de se
fabriquer des dispositions à s'engager
tellement intériorisé qu'elles peuvent
lui semblait naturel tout à fait ça
savoir mon sens ce que tu dis là c'est
une troisième problématique qui est
parallèle évidemment à celle ci
puisque ce que tu viens de dire la
permet de comprendre pourquoi est ce que
certaines personnes vont s'engager ici
mais tu as à mon sens quelque chose
d'autre encore ici dans cet article
voilà abbas et un stream assez court
aujourd'hui
petite quarantaine de minutes faut dire
que la semaine dernière on avait fait
pas mal alors je rappelle que vous allez
retrouver
pardon la vidéo de
de ce stream un peu monté mais je veux
vraiment je j'enlève le début et le
blabla de la fin sur la chaîne youtube
je vais poster ça dans quelques dents
quelques dizaines de minutes le temps de
faire le petit travail de montage
à tueur explique le rapport avec le
féminisme ici le truc c'est qu'elle elle
patauge un petit peu dans son objet
d'étude elle voit pas trop comment
sortir de cette problématique qui est
l'engagement politique
le bénévolat comme engagement politique
parce que sur le terrain se rend compte
que c'est pas ça sur le terrain elles se
rencontrent rend compte que les acteurs
parlent du bénévolat com com du travail
finalement
est en fait c'est via cette lecture
féministe qu'elle peut faire un
parallèle entre le travail domestique et
le travail bénévole
une apnée des travaux féministes ont
montré que le travail domestique qui est
du vrai travail productif puisque
d'ailleurs si tu engages du personnel de
maison ben voilà il va faire ce
travail-là contre rémunération donc
c'est bien la preuve qu'il s'agit d'un
travail
économique au sens du terme
c'est un travail au sens économique du
terme voilà c'est un peu mieux formuler
et donc
l'invisibilisation du travail domestique
comme production d'un service
économiquement valorisables j'ai pas dit
valorisent et g10 valorisables et bien
finalement elle se rend compte que c'est
la même chose avec le travail bénévole
et que ce sont les femmes qui sont
victimes de ce travail bénévole fin de
cette exploitation via le travail
bénévole ou finalement il ya quand même
une valeur économique qui crée mais qui
est tout à fait un visibiliser comme le
travail domestique et c'est là que le
lien entre entre les travaux féministes
qui sont ici au dessus hein
et le bénévolat voilà
c'est dans cette source y qu'elle
constate que
elle peut faire le lien entre les deux
quoi
oui c'est ça donc l'engagement une forme
de militantisme
ça c'était le comment dire la
problématique
initiale en fait tous les travaux
qu'elle lit elle se rend compte que ils
sont dans cette veine-là mail c'est en
contradiction avec ce qui se passe sur
le terrain sur le terral constate que
les gens ne se font pas du bénévolat
comme comme une forme de militantisme
ils font du bénévolat corps en faisant
le lien avec du travail quoi pour eux
c'est souvent comme du travail alors
après à toute cette dimension évidemment
de se faire bien voir et d'être
récompensés par des valeurs mais un
travail qui n'est qui est gratuit et qui
n'est pas de ceux-là rémunéré ni
valorisé
ça va
voilà si tu n'as plus de questions
ok c'est clair voilà je sais pas si ça
taïder j'espère que ça va aider que ça
aidera évidemment tout faisait et celle
qui travailleront sur le bénévolat qui
tomberont sur cette vidéo
non ça c'est un concept qui est pas paru
sur
sur le à bonjour tva
tu vas bien mais avec plaisir tout un
article assez court aujourd'hui c'était
voilà pour aider un peu vers alex dans
ses travaux voilà on se retrouve
mercredi ou jeudi 1 pour une émission
plus politique
voilà parce qu'il ya plus de questions
et on va en rester là je vous remercie
en tout cas d'être venu je vous remercie
de votre soutien à ces stream et je vous
dis à très bientôt pour un prochain
stream et je vous souhaite une bonne
semaine un bon là dit salut salut
mais
un civilisation moi je le vois pas dans
le texte
moi je n'ai pas utilisé ce mot là
moi j'ai dit
invisibilisation
d'ailleurs tu vois le terme invisible
c'est même dans son dans son article
dans l'article qu'elle trouve
parce qu'en fait tu vois là invisible
invisible parce que c'est du travail qui
pas valoriser aux yeux de la société
quoi ils passent comme invisible
maintenant c'est invisibilisation j'ai
peut-être mal articuler
un
visibilisation tu vois
tout simplement voilà c'est ce qui est
montré comme travail productif ou pas
quoi
elle le terme se retrouvent trois fois
regarde ici à une autre référence c'est
le travail qu'elle a fait avec krynski
déni de travail invisibilisation du
travail d'aujourd'hui
donc voilà si vous voulez en savoir plus
avec votre groupe peut-être aller sur
cet article a qui a l'air relativement
intéressant
abbey super et c'est quoi vos hypothèses
cain c'est quoi la question vous est
posée
et les hypothèses que vous avez
formulées par rapport à ça ça peut être
intéressant
alors je rappelle aussi
en attendant la réponse de verre alex
qu' il y aura à 22h la possibilité de
voter pour l'article de la semaine
prochaine
vous retrouver ça sur la chaîne youtube
sur l'onglet communauté
voilà il n'est pas encore présent c'est
à 22h qui sera publié et donc vous
pouvez faire votre choix déjà pour la
semaine prochaine le premier nous
parlera du parcours de scolarisation de
trois élèves hp j'essaie toujours
d'avoir un thème un peu plus colère je
sais que ça plaît 1 les vécus et la
perception des élèves leurs parents et
des enseignants donc à mon avis un
article qui plaira soit aux hp aux
parents d'acheter et peut-être aux
enseignants de manière générale
alors le deuxième thème je trouvais que
c'était particulièrement percutant en
terme de titre c'était la pulvérisation
démocratique où les clivages façon
puzzle alors ça c'est assez marrant
parce que c'est le film les tontons
flingueurs un film que j'adore c'est un
film vraiment culte chaque fois qu'ils
passent à la télé je le regarde je
regarde aussi parfois en stream
tellement que c'est un c'est un film je
trouve drôle et donc là c'est un super
intéressant parce que il nous montre à
quel point les individus les acteurs
sont de plus en plus atomisé dans le
champ politique donc c'est à dire qu'on
est de moins en moins pris aussi en tant
que citoyen aux collecteurs dans des des
identités collectives
et nous explique que voilà c'est un peu
le cas de tout le champ politique et du
coup on comprend mieux l'émergence de
certaines personnalités fortes parce qu
on est en voie de à une personnalisation
de la politique donc ça c'est un truc à
mon avis qui est un peu plus théorique
mais voilà ça me plaît beaucoup
donc ça c'est le thème un peu politique
de la semaine et puis troisième thème
beaucoup plus sociale
inégalités sociales disposition et
usages du numérique
donc là c'est aussi intéressant avec les
notions dix exclusions dit l'électro
nisme pardon
et tout ce qui est lié à la fracture
numérique donc ça peut être aussi
intéressant donc ça vous pouvez voter
jusqu'au vendredi puis après voilà je
relève les votes et à ce moment là le
choix est fait pour le dimanche
alors la grande question est quelles
sont les motivations et les intérêts des
personnes à s'engager dans une
association où ils ne sont pas payés
plutôt que de travailler alors ici tu
auras tout cet aspect directement a tiré
de l'article c'est le côté du
jeu reprend l'article
tout cet aspect
[Musique]
en tout cas des travaux d'intérêts
généraux quale welfare
to work ici un où on est obligé de les
allocataires voilà qui sont obligés de
participer à certains travaux bénévoles
en fait pour garder pour gagner pour
garder leurs allocations
donc ça c'est une première chose et tu
vois
ce qui est intéressant c'est les
chiffres 75 % sont des femmes et à 92%
elles sont noires ou sondés latinas
donc ça c'est intéressant
sinon je réfléchis comment directement
trouver des éléments percutant par
rapport à ça
en tout cas voilà ici on n'est pas sûr
sur une logique d'engagement militant
quoi ça tu l'aura bien compris
mais plutôt way sur une logique de
valorisation comme tu le disais dans ton
message précédent
je me redresse pas ce que j'ai en train
de maaf aller sur le fauteuil
on a recours on a rencontré si les
actions touchent
n'est pas un élément des significations
des actions sociales pour les bénévoles
quelque chose naturelle ouais ici dans
ce texte c'est dans cet article ci a
comme moi - cette dimension de la
socialisation
parce que d'ailleurs c'est le moment je
vais relever dans le dans l'article où
j'avais dit que j'aimais bien ce passage
là
mais l'on parle pas plus
voilà jusqu'où peut-on alors
sérieusement utiliser le même terme
d'exploitation pour désigner également
l'utilisation par la ville du travail de
ses lecteurs qui sont en grande partie
là aussi des actrices bénévoles bonne
voisine et bonne citoyenne issus des
classes moyennes supérieures que rien a
priori n'oblige à être là sinon toute la
panoplie des normes sociales et genre et
quoi donc là il ya peut-être aussi une
approche si vous ne l'avez pas encore
c'est sur l'aspect genre et pourquoi est
ce que les femmes sont plus poussés par
le bénévole est donc toute une analyse
aussi qui est que le travail
des femmes qu'ils soient bénévoles ou
domestique est un visibiliser et nos
classes
il faudra aller retourner dans les
travaux pour voir ce que ça dit quoi
parce qu'à mon avis tu a pas d'élément
de réponse directe ici
ouais
ouais je sais pas je sais pas je ne sais
pas ça dépasse mes mes capacités
les méconnaissances
en tout cas
bon ben voila
moi j'en ai fini avec
cet article on se retrouve
plus tard
merci encore vers alex pour pour l'idée
de l'article merci au tva pour le
passage
sur le stream merci aux autres voilà qui
qui n'êtes pas présent sur le chat mecs
qui avaient regardé ce stream c'est bien
sympa et je vous dis à bientôt à
mercredi salut salut tu